Norma gun with Beast I'm gonna do with
chicken this is a really nice light
healthy approaches all gloss and so
simple to do chicken breast slice smoked
paprika and gives it a really nice oak
smoky flavor
salt pepper rub across the chicken
hot pan olive oil
the most important part now just rightly
so taking the chicken giving it a little
bit of color
rest vegetables onions peppers garlic
mushrooms
see your here is we're setting the
vegetables off in the same pan as the
chicken gently infusing the vegetables
white wine
reduce
chicken stock sour cream chicken sugar
snap peas parsley
rest and to finish off is this little
baby here specially basically Germans
pasta it's light its fluffy but more
important is gonna be crispy seasoned
hot pan olive oil as it hits the pan it
puffs up it's nice and light butter
stroganoff
that has to be the perfect strong enough
smoke paprika chicken stroganoff bits
pet silly done the crispy topping do you
think one that deserves to be a great
British classic ready in under ten
minutes but eaten in seconds